Transcriber: Esin K
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Merhaba.
İroniye “acı çikolata”
demeyi tercih ettim.
Size bugün örneklerle, elimden geldiğince
ve çok fazla kavramsallaştırmadan
benim kendi dünyamda edebiyat anlayışımıza
ve yaşama yordamında ironinin yeri nedir
biraz ondan bahsedeceğim.
Yıllar önce biraz gençlik cesareti ve
coşkusuyla sahneye çıktığım zaman,
o zamanlar ve tabii ki şu anda da
yaygın ismiyle stand-up
yapmak üzere sahneye çıktığım zaman
afişlerde adımı gören çoğu izleyici
Figen Şakacı’nın “şakacı” kısmının
takma bir soyad olduğuna
neredeyse emindiler.
Sanmışlar ki hani ben oraya çıkacağım,
komik hikâyeler anlatacağım,
iddiamı da adımın arkasına yapıştıracağım.
Yani daha seyirci gelmeden
güleceğini garanti edecek
bir soyad alacağım.
Düşünebiliyor musunuz, hayatım boyunca
bütün devlet kurumlarında
bir kerede soyadımı anlayan hiç olmadı.
Her defasında gülünecek
şey “şaka”dan geliyor,
“saka” değil, “sakar” değil falan diye.
Yani “çakıcı” diyen bile duydum
öyle söyleyeyim size.
O yüzden bunları böyle anlatmak için
verdiğim çabadan sonra
bir de sahneye çıkınca, bu ikisi
bence yeterince ironik bir hâl almıştı.
Yani ironi aslına bakarsanız
tam da kelime anlamında
her ne kadar sözlere dayalı,
gülümsettiği kadar acıtmayı da içeren
bir tanımı olmasına rağmen
ben daha çok söze yaslanmayan,
durumun kendisinden kaynaklı ve
ağızda hem acı tatlı bir lezzet bırakan
tanımın kendisini
daha yakın bulurum.
Bu anlattığım hani “sahneye çıktı, herkesi
güldürecek,
o yüzden de soyadını ‘şakacı’ olarak
bilinsin istiyor” tanımından sonra
ben tabii sahneye çıkıp aslında
bu ülkede bir kadın olmak ne demektir
ve bu kadının başına neler gelir gibi
acı tatlı hikâyeler anlatıyordum.
O zamanlar, yani 90′ların ortalarında
böyle hikâyeler anlatan
üstelik tiyatro sahnesinde değil de
bir bar ortamında anlatan kadınları
biraz yadırgıyorlardı, özellikle
erkek seyirciler çok yadırgıyordu.
Fakat en bence ironik tepki de
bir kadın izleyicimden gelmişti.
Beni dinledikten sonra, sahneden indikten
sonra önüme çıkıp şey dedi:
″Figen Hanım, gerçekten harikaydınız!
Yani gülmemek için kendimi
zor tuttum,″ dedi.
Şimdi hani stand-up şovunun kendi özü
itibariyle zaten hani böyle bir
eğlendirmeyi, eğlendirmeyi niyet etmiş
bir gösterinin içinde
böyle bir yorum alınca ben de ″keşke
tutmasaydınız kendinizi″ diyesim oldu.
Tabii aslında bu gelenek bize, yani
örneklerle anlatmaya devam edersem,
mesela benim için ironiye en güzel
örneklerden biri
çocukluk yıllarımda hatırladığım
Laurel & Hardy idi.
Bunlardan bir tanesi böyle çok kurnaz,
çok akıllı imiş gibi durur,
diğeri de böyle çok saftirik,
çok, ne derler,
her an başına bela gelse
kimsenin şaşırmayacağı bir karakterdir.
Burada söze yaslanmayan, sadece
durumların kendisinden kaynaklı
birtakım eğlenceli,
ne diyeyim size, size ilk sessiz filmleri,
ilk sessiz komedi filmini
örnek olarak verebiliriz Laurel & Hardy’i.
Tabii yani, ancak benim kuşağımın
hatırlayabileceği bir örnek verdim.
Belki de şu anda beni dinleyen Açı
öğrencilerinin annelerinden bahsediyorum.
Tabii anneanneleri dedeleri demeyeyim ki
kendi yaşımı da çok ortaya çıkarmayayım.
Onların, yani oradaki
karşılıklı birbirlerini,
birbirlerini düşürdükleri durumlar.
Daha sonra ben de Türkiye tiyatrosunda,
tiyatro geleneğinde
Kavuklu ile Pişekar’a çok tekabül eden,
yine bu sefer söze dayalı,
küçük küçük atışmalarla ilerleyen
ve tiyatro geleneğimizde meddahlığa
doğru yol açan el veren
ve yine işte bir akıllı, bir hafif, biri
kurnaz biri saf iki karakter üzerinden
seyircinin çok da özdeşlik
kurmakta zorlanmadığı
iki karakter üzerinden
anlatabiliriz ironiyi.
Edebiyatta ise özellikle benim
Türkçe edebiyatta
ironi deyince usta olarak gördüğüm,
yegâne benim açımdan,
tabii ki çok lezzetli, ironik tatlar
bırakan yazarlarımız var
ama benim usta olarak gördüğüm
Oğuz Atay’dır.
Tutunamayanlar kitabını
20′li ve 30′lu yaşlarımda
iki kere okumamın sebebi;
oradaki ironik anlatımları,
onların göndermelerini,
onların göndermelerinin izini sürmek ve
oradaki o böyle gülerken
içimin hafif sızlamasına engel olamadan
okumaya iştahla devam edebilmekti.
Tabii ki aynı ironik ton, kadın
yazarlarımızdan Leyla Erbil’de,
Sevgi Soysal’da da, özellikle
Sevgi Soysal’ın
Yürümek kitabında da
çok sık rastlayacağınız ve çok sert,
yine acı çikolata diyebileceğimiz
bir tatta rastlayabileceğimiz
üslubundan gelir.
Benim kendi edebiyatımda özellikle
Bitirgen ve Pala Hayriye’yi yazarken
niyetim tabii ki bir mizah
ya da mizahi bir dille yazılmış
bir roman olması değildi
ama Bitirgen’in ve Hayriye’nin
kendini içinde bulduğu
ya da bizatihi, bile isteye içine düştüğü
durumların kendisinin
ironik olduğunu daha sonra
okur yorumlarından,
kitaplarımla gibi yapılan eleştirilerden
daha iyi anladım.
Ama yine bence ironiye bir
örnek olarak verebilirim.
Bitirgen’i gibi 5 yıl gibi çok uzun bir
sürede yazdım
ve gerçekten çok, ne diyeyim size,
sancılı bir süreçti.
Bir kız çocuğu hikâyesi
anlatmak istiyordum
ve o sırada henüz bir kız çocuğuydum.
Annemin küçük, hafif asi kız çocuğuydum
ve tek istediğim Bitirgen’i bitirip
anneme, ’’İşte, bak bir kız
çocuğu hikâyesi anlattım.
Senin kız çocuğun işte yazar oldu, böyle
bir hikaye anlattı,’′ demek istiyordum
fakat annem Bitirgen’i göremeden
bu dünyadan gitti.
Daha sonra ironi belki şudur ki,
annemin kitapta ana dilimi, annemin dilini
edebiyat dünyasına sokmak,
orada özellikle bazı deyimlerini
kendi literatürümüze, sözlüğümüze,
gündelik dilimize
Bitirgen aracılığıyla,
bir roman karakteri aracılığıyla
karıştırmak gibi kendimce,
ne diyeyim,
bir sadece yazarlık değil,
küçük de bir evlatlık görevi
yaptığımı düşünüyorum.
Daha sonra Bitirgen’i okuyan
çoğu okurdan hep şöyle yorumlar aldım:
″Ay o kadar güldüm ki okurken,
o kadar güldüm ki!″ falan diye
çok söylemeye başlıyorlardı.
Ben de için için bozulmaya,
bozuluyordum yani.
″Ben yazarken hiç de o kadar gülmedim,
ne var bunda bu kadar gülünecek?″ diye.
Sonra aslında,
gülmeyle ağlamanın ya da
içerde bu tür duygusal
noktalarımızı, sinir uçlarını
dürtmenin dille,
kurguyla, edebiyatla mümkün olabileceğini
ve bunu bir nebze de olsa başarabildiğimi
gördüm ve çok sevindim.
Tabii zaten hani ben ironiye
“acı çikolata” falan dedim ama
kavramsallaştırmamaya çalışsam da,
aslında bizim
bizzat bunun yegâne karşılığı
bir deyim olarak vardır.
O da hani,
″Gülüyoruz ağlanacak halimize″dir.
Dolayısıyla ironi; aslında
komik olmayı hedeflemez,
güldürmeyi, güldürme niyetiyle yola çıkmaz
ama mutlaka orada
böyle bir pusuda bekleyen
sinsi bir şey mutlaka vardır.
Ya durumun kendisinde ya
sözün sivriliğinde,
böyle iki ucunda böyle ışıl ışıl parlayan,
mutlaka zekâyla beslenen,
var olan durumu çok tasarruflu
bir dille özetleyen
ve karşısındaki kişide
mutlak katarsis yaratan bir
durumun bizzat kendisidir bence ironi.
Bunu tabi dediğim gibi mesela,
dünya edebiyatında da bence
en iyi yapanlardan biri
benim için Philip Roth’tur.
O da kendi mensup olduğu
Yahudi cemaatine, edebiyat ortamına,
Amerika gibi büyük
ve çok çeşitli kültürlerin
yer aldığı bir yerde,
hafif de böyle bir küfürbazlığa kaçarak
çok sert ve çok ironik bir üslupla
kitaplarında çok sağlam hikâyeler
anlatır bence.
Tabii aslında hani her şeyin dışında,
tepeden baktığımızda
yaşadığımız kültürel
ve sosyal etkilerle de
ironiye bakışımızın ve bizatihi ironik
bir hâlin içinde hemhâl oluşumuzun,
yaşayıp gidişimizin de bence
tam bu “ironi nedir” sorusuna
bir cevap olduğunu düşünüyorum.
O da bence hani,
dışarıdan bakanların,
yurt dışında yaşayanların,
bu ülkede yaşayan, yaşayanlara dair
bizim kendi vatandaşlık durumumuza dair
yaptığı tanımlardır.
İşte ″Ya aslında Türkiye çok
eğlenceli bir memleket.
Yani yaşamasak bayağı
eğlenirdik, gülerdik,″
demeleri de bence hâlimizin
ironisini çok iyi özetliyor.
Çok da kızamıyorum bunu diyenlere
çünkü hani her gün ekonomik krizin
boğazımıza kadar geldiği bir zamanda,
özellikle petrol fiyatlarının.
Hani diyeceksiniz ki ne alaka
ama düşünün her gün zam gelen
bir akaryakıt, petrol fiyatlarını
biz aşk şarkısı yazıp
Eurovision’a katılmış
bir memleketin efradıyız.
O yüzden ironiyi yaşadığınız her alanda
ve her anda
görmeniz ve bizzat o ironinin öznesi
olmanız kaçınılmazdır.
Dinlediğiniz için hepinize çok
ama çok teşekkür ederim.
Hoşçakalın.